Well if we add 32 on the left side of the equation, then we need to subtract 32
from the same side. This should make a total of 0 on the left hand side of the
equation. And we'd be left with 2x squared like here, minus 16x here, plus 33
here. This is why these two equations are exactly the same. The other way that
we can think about it is that if we add 32 on the right hand side of the
equation, then we add 32 on the left hand side of the equation. We could just
subtract the 32 to get the y alone, and we wind up with this equation. Since we
want the equation to be in the form y equals, it's best to go ahead an subtract
32, from the same side that we add 32. We can just skip the step of adding 32
on both sides, so long as we subtract the 32, since we added 32 here.